hi everyone and backstage with jason
biggs to celebrate his new game show
cash at your door and we're gonna give
three audience members a chance to win
some cash by answering trivia questions
including liliana who has no idea that
we're about to surprise her no idea and
i love trivia i love trivia okay let's
give away money let's do this
[Music]
please welcome drew barrymore
welcome
everyone we're continuing this week with
all things nifty and thrifty but today
we aren't just saving money
okay
we're actually gonna give away some
money
uh here to help us do that actually is a
hilarious brilliant actor we've known
for many years and he's the host of the
new game show cash at your door he's
also a very good friend of the show i
think this is his third time it's jason
[Applause]
big hello
i don't realize i didn't even realize
what a sick view you have from this
studio thank you very much incredible
yeah we like all things gold and warm
and amber
flowery yellow sunshine let's wake up on
the sunny side of this
whatever it is
the camera um you know what else makes
everybody in a good mood
cash money sure does um
now
i watched um cash at your door i love it
it's trivia-based questions tell us
about it yeah sure so cash out your door
it's pretty much all there in the title
i show up at people's houses they are
not expecting me all right they think
they're taking part in a show about
their homes but they have no idea i'm
showing up or that they could win up to
25 000 in cash by answering trivia
questions so that's it that's the show
serious money yeah the game show takes
place
in their home so i'm sitting down with
these wonderful people in their living
rooms asking them trivia questions and
uh people win a lot of money and as you
can imagine in the last year this was uh
it was very welcome i was very welcome
and people had a lot of fun so it was
great okay well we aren't at anyone's
house right now but we are here with our
audience so we're going to put our own
twist on it and call it cash at your
seat love it
thank you
um okay so we've selected a few audience
members to participate throughout the
show today and first up is jason take it
away okay here we go first up is liliana
liliana zapata where is liliana where
are you
[Applause]
juliana yeah come on down here
oh my god
hi liliana how are you hi jason hi
from queens from queens right on all
right here we go queen from queens yes
oh okay liliana halloween is around the
corner and in honor of all those scary
movies out
what film is the famous quote i see dead
people from is it hocus pocus
ghostbusters scream or the sixth sense
the sixth sentence
[Applause]
congratulations
nice
thank you
i know
i mean cash makes a huge difference it
really does seeing it it's like
i'm glad you do it yes we're trying to
do it all right so we're going to do
this throughout the hour jake okay i'm
i'm ready i'm psyched today and then
we're gonna have a sit-down talk and
we're just gonna keep doing that it's
gonna keep getting getting people paid
yes exactly okay
everyone else is going to too
all right
does anyone want to win a little money
[Applause]
hi again all right fancy meeting you
here meeting you
are you ready for our next contestant i
sure am all right what's his name his
name is hayden
baker
hayden baker
he is
come on down here
it's funny i really want to say come on
down but it's not you know the price is
right
i know well we're paying homage and by
the way it's now hosted by a guy named
drew so i think we're good
i love drew carey he came on the show
and he was like one of my he's my second
favorite drew
thank you yeah who's the first drew
brees drew brees yeah of course
mine too
now hayden i heard you had some mishaps
this year you like dislocated a hip a
kneecap you broke a few bones yeah that
is jesus you want to sit down dude
drew barry no more knows two things
about me my name and that i have broken
a lot of bones this year so
i hope you win some cash today
[Applause]
me too
wow all right hayden here we go in honor
of captain kirk aka william shatner
going to outer space what is the nearest
planet to the sun is it earth
mercury pluto or jupiter
okay well shout out to my mom for making
sure i knew this growing up oh
shout out mom mercury
[Applause]
congratulations
[Applause]
that's enough for a new kneecap
[Laughter]
thank you so much for at least a heap
ton of ice cream and an elevated pillow
you deserve it hayden thank you so much
all right
we'll be right back
in what classic sitcom did mary kate and
ashley olson both play the character
michelle tanner
full house is
oh
yeah that's correct that's correct of
course it is for 250 nicely done who am
i giving this to okay very good
wasting no time can i come in can we
continue playing
fantastic come on in guys here we go
before you go
i think we have time for one more round
of cash
okay
all right
our last contestant out here is
lachey ortiz lachey
hi lachey
come on down how you doing lashay i'm
doing great thank you for all that you
do because i know
that you're a volunteer
and you donate a lot of your time at
food banks
[Applause]
that's amazing
i feel like we should
[Music]
i feel like we should up the stakes for
lachey
i think we should all right let's see
what's going to happen if you answer
this question right okay you will win
wait really a thousand dollars
[Applause]
all right are you ready yes no presh
here we go
halloween is the spookiest time of year
with many things to be frightful of
acrophobia is the fear of
what is it
spiders acronyms heights or confined
places acrophobia
i think it's heights
no
you're correct answer
is
[Applause]
jason cash at your door airs tuesday
nights on e such a happy good channel
what a perfect place for this show
and um i can't wait until our next
adventure
give my best to jenny and the kids
[Music]
you